>> Bret: GET INSIGHT INTO THE
IRAN ISSUE AROUND THE GLOBE.
JOINING US TONIGHT SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
JUST LISTENED TO YOUR BOSS SAID
YOU NEED TO GO TO THE U.N. AND
GET THE SANCTIONS.
YOU SAID THAT YOU HAVE EVERY
EXPECTATION THAT U.N. SECURITY
COUNCIL DO DO THAT.
WHAT MAKE YOU THINK THAT?
>> I HEAD UP THERE TOMORROW
AFTERNOON, I MEET WITH THE
SECURITY COUNCIL PRESIDENT AND
THE SECRETARY GENERAL WILL
PROVIDE NOTIFICATION OF THE
SNAPBACK AND 30 DAYS FROM NOW,
ALL THE SANCTIONS THAT WERE IN
PLACE WILL RESUME.
THEY HAVE BEEN TEMPORARILY PAUSE
PAUSED BECAUSE OF THE RIDICULOUS
NUCLEAR DEAL.
ALL THE THINGS THAT POSE RISK IN
THE MIDDLE EAST, THE GULF STATES
ARE ALL EXCITED ABOUT ISRAEL IS
EXCITED ABOUT IT.
>> Bret: WHEN CHINA OR RUSSIA
REFUSE, IS THE ADMINISTRATION
GOING TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
WITH SANCTIONS TOO?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE’VE ALREADY DONE THAT.
WHEN WE SEEN ANY COUNTRY VIOLATE
OUR SANCTIONS --
>> Bret: WHAT DOES IT SAY WHEN
YOU TRIES TO GET THE ARMS
EMBARGO ON IRAN?
>> IT’S REALLY UNFORTUNATE.
IT MAKES THE EUROPEAN PEOPLE
LESS SAFE.
PRIVATELY THESE COUNTRIES ALL
TELL ME THEY WANT ARMS EMBARGO
EXTENDED.
THEY REFUSE TO DO THE COURAGEOUS
THING THE MORALLY RIGHT THING
AND VOTE IN SUPPORT OF EXTENDING
IT ALL FOR SOME HOLY GRAIL OF
JCPOA.
THE WORLD NEEDS TO KNOW.
WE’LL DO THE RIGHT THING.
WE’LL KEEP THE WORLD SAFER.
HOPE -- WE HOPE THE EUROPEANS
WILL COME TO SEE IT THIS WAY AS
WELL.
>> Bret: IN THAT VAIN, CAN THE
U.S. WORK WITH THE EUROPEANS
WHEN IT COMES TO IRAN?
>> WE FOUND PLACES WE CAN DO
THAT ALREADY.
WE’VE WORKED ON STRAIGHTS IN
HAMUS.
THEY ARE WEDDED TO THIS CRAZY
NUCLEAR DEAL.
THEY TRYING TO HANG ON TO IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE CLEAR THEY
WILL NOT HAVE A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
THEY SHOULD DO THE RAKE THING
FOR THE WORLD.
THIS IS NOW THE FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FIRST ELEMENT
OF THE JCPOA TO EXPIRE.
WE’RE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
WE’RE GOING TO GET U.N.
SANCTIONS PUT BACK IN PLACE.
>> Bret: THE JCPOA IS THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL.
DO YOU THINK THE EUROPEANS LIKE
THE GERMANS WENT TO SELL WEAPONS
TO IRAN?
>> NO, I DON’T THINK THAT’S IT.
I THINK THEY HAVE SOME ODD
NOTION THAT SOMEHOW THIS IS
ACTUALLY PROTECTING AND
PRESERVING SOME RISK THAT THE
IRANIANS WILL BEGIN THEIR
NUCLEAR WEAPONS PROGRAM.
WE’VE NOW THROUGH THE SANCTIONS
WE’VE PUT IN PLACE OVER
$200 BILLION TO THE ISLAMIC
REPUBLIC OF IRAQ.
I THINK THE PEOPLE OF EUROPE
UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE RIGHT
THING.
I THINK THEIR LEADERS DO TOO.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK THE
SNAPBACK ESSENTIALLY KILLS THE
JCPOA?
THAT DEAL IS DONE AND CANNOT BE
RESURRECTED EVEN IF THERE IS A
PRESIDENT BIDEN?
>> I KNOW THIS.
I KNOW THAT THE RESOLUTIONS THAT
WERE PUT IN PLACE HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE FOR OVER A DECADE NOW.
WE’LL.WILL BE BACK IN EFFECT.
I THINK IT’S THE CASE THAT ALL
OF THE ELEMENTS, ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT SECRETARY KERRY HAVE
BROUGHT UPON, WILL NO LONGER BE
THE CASE.
>> Bret: LAST NIGHT KERRY SPOKE
AT THE DNC.
HE SPOKE ABOUT IRAN.
HERE’S THE FIRST ONE ON IRAN.
>> FOR THE EIGHT YEARS OF THE
OBAMA-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WE
LED BY EXAMPLE.
WE ELIMINATED THE THREAT OF AN
IRAN WITH A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
>> Bret: HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> THAT’S FALSE.
THEY LED FROM BEHIND.
THAT WAS THEIR MOTTO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP LEADS FROM THE
FRONT.
HE’S PREPARE TO TAKE THE STAND.
THEY DIDN’T STOP IRAN FROM
HAVING NUCLEAR WEAPON.
THEY PROVIDED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SO IRAN CAN CONTINUE THE
NUCLEAR ENRICHMENT PROGRAM.
THEY PUT THEMSELVES ON PATHWAY
TO NUCLEAR WEAPON.
THAT’S WHAT THE DEAL WAS.
>> Bret: JOHN KERRY ON RUSSIA?
>> DONALD TRUMP PRETENDS RUSSIA
DIDN’T ATTACK OUR ELECTIONS.
NOW HE DOES NOTHING ABOUT RUSSIA
PUTTING BOUNTY ON OUR TROOPS.
>> TWO PIECES TO THAT.
THERE’S BEEN NO PRESIDENT
TOUGHER ON RUSSIA WHETHER THAT’S
OUR DEFENSE BUILD UP, WHETHER
IT’S THE WORK WE’VE DONE TO
PROVIDE WEAPON SYSTEMS TO
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
JOHN KERRY AND VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN REFUSE TO DO THAT.
I’M CONFIDENT THAT THE RUSSIANS
WOULD RATHER HAVE THAT POLICY.
WE’VE BEEN TOUGH ON RUSSIA.
WE’VE SANCTIONED HUNDREDS OF
RUSSIANS FOR THEIR MALIGN
ACTIVITY.
THIS TAKES BACKSEAT TO NO ONE
STANDING UP TO AMERICA,
PROTECTING OUR SECURITY AND
GETTING IT RIGHT WITH RESPECT TO
RUSSIA.
WHETHER THAT’S RUSSIAN EFFORT IN
AFGHANISTAN, SYRIA OR UKRAINE.
>> Bret: IN YOUR TALKS WITH THE
RUSSIANS, DID YOU BRING UP
ALLEGED BOUNTIES U.S. TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN?
>> I DID.
IT’S SOMETHING THAT WILL BE TRUE
COST FOR.
>> Bret: HERE’S COLIN POWELL.
>> HE WILL TRUST OUR DIPLOMAT
AND INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
NOT THE FLATTERY OF DICTATORS.
>> Bret: RESPONSE?
>> I HAVE LOT OF RESPECT FOR
GENERAL POWELL.
I KNOWN HIM FOR A KNOWN TIME.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHEN I WAS
CIA DIRECTOR, I VALUED
INFORMATION THAT I PROVIDED HIM.
NOW AMERICA’S MOST SENIOR PLEDGE
MAT -- DIPLOMAT.
I WATCHED HIM VALUE THESE PEOPLE
IN IMPORTANT WAYS.
I’M NOT SURE WHAT IT WAS GENERAL
POWELL WAS SPEAKING TO THERE.
>> Bret: LAST THING, ONE THING
THAT HAS NOT COME UP A LOT, I
GUESS LAST NIGHT WAS FOREIGN
POLICY.
WE’LL HEAR IT MAY COME UP AGAIN.
CHINA HAS NOT COME UP.
IS THAN OPENING FOR REPUBLICANS
NEXT WEEK ON THAT ISSUE AND WHAT
YOU’RE DOING?
>> I’M TERRIBLY SURPRISED
DEMOCRATS HAVEN’T TALKED ABOUT
FOREIGN POLICY ENOUGH WITH NO
MENTIONS OF CHINA.
THE SINGLE GREATEST CHALLENGE TO
THE UNITED STATES OTHER THE NEXT
YEARS.
SINGLE GREATEST THREATS TO THE
UNITED STATES COMES FROM THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY.
DONALD TRUMP CALLED IT EARLY.
HE TALKED ABOUT IT IN 2015 AND
2016.
FOR 3.5 YEARS WE’VE IMPOSED COST
ON CHINA THAT PROTECTED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM THIS
THREAT.
WHEN THEY REFUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
WUHAN VIRUS, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
AIMING TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE ENORMOUS LOSS OF LIFE
ALL ACROSS THE WORLD AND THE
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
HARM THAT THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY ALLOWED TO PERMEATE ALL
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
>> Bret: WE APPRECIATE YOUR